hi thank you for the opportunity to add
another context in which a Python can be
quite an ND tool as you may guess from
the title of my talk my case study
concern history because I am an
historian at present I work at a
university and I have been using a
Python ahora working through a data set
of a bibliographic records that have
been building as part of my project my
research concerns a history of
agricultural meteorology in a nutshell
agriculture meteorology he is the
discipline that studies how weather and
climate affect farming and this is a
great concern especially today in times
of climate change my bibliographic data
set the concerns information about books
articles I know the titles I know bee
hotels and over here of publication so
far it's quite a huge data set for an
historian because historian usually are
bright histories go into archives
looking at a particular scientist or a
particular institution in this case I
have publications that appear the Hinna
very many countries in a very many
journals several languages what can I do
with them I had a visa idea but the data
were interesting but I then didn't have
amateurs to go through visa data and it
was a pity because I felt that they
could help me to answer questions about
how interdisciplinary is agricultural
meteorology whether there was a trend in
time for a publication what were the
popular topics in the field in which
journals I did with people publish we're
way meteorology journal agricultural
German mix the journals so I first met
her I needed a something to use within
Python Awards a great resource
hi had the opportunity to learn Python
as part of an initiative to teach her IT
skills that women learn IT girl I had a
mentor and
she helped me to set up a project and to
grow through my records using a panda's
and speci I very much like the working
with Madonna and I am grateful to the
community but around spite on because I
you get a lot of support when I started
I really knew nothing about Python and
the tools like Stack Overflow
really helped me apart from my mentor
the work that I have been doing has
mainly used a panda and a spacey
because I didn't just look at the data
but also for instance I looked through
the titles of a publications I cannot
tell you in detail how all there is
answer but I would just like her to
point out a few things for instance the
journal articles of it are of a biggest
chunk of my result of my dataset proved
very interesting because for instance
when I paired with the Jorma categories
and I did it by hand what turned out is
that several large majority of these
publications were printed in
agricultural journals so you sort of a
heaven indication as an historian of it
probably the agricultural community was
closer to these problems of enemy
meteorological community and I was
always kind of information adjuster came
out because I could go through the data
with quantitative methods that usually
historians that don't have I was also
very surprised when I looked at what
were the popular themes with Pacey I
just looked at Roubaix English German so
with the titles of English journal
articles because it was the easiest
thing to do and paradoxically the most
popular
lemma was not planted was not a lighter
was not climate it was temperature and
this was a quiet and expected because of
for instance many people say that it was
a rain of the most important sector but
evidently the publications such as the
different things you may think that this
is not much but I must say
from the point of view of a historian
and it usually has two bright small
stories and try to work out bigger a
bigger picture from a small story the
possibility to start from a big picture
of a dataset and to go through it in a
systematic way was definitely a very
nice thing so I am really grateful to
the people who made this possible and
invested to Shinto and I think that
Python for me as an historian has proved
a very important tool and I see that
within the academic community there is
an increasing interest for me as a
digital tools and I definitely would
like to learn more and I hope of it
being in Berlin and working in Berlin
ever would be a possibility to sort of
increase my skills with Python and to
make something more about it thank you
[Applause]